for some reason I don't want to call
those fast times at the El Royale like
it's ridgemont high or some [ __ ] I don't
know why bad times at the El Royale so
bad times at the El Royale is written
and directed by Drew Goddard he directed
I believe wrote cabin in the woods also
and this man you explained this movie
essentially there's this hotel with the
state line division of California Nevada
going right through it this hotel is
divided by these Tuesdays so one half of
the hotels Nevada one half of the hotels
California and there's money involved
and a lot of people at this hotel for
different reasons it concentrates on
someone does a flashback on their story
then concentrates on the perspective of
someone else while that thing was
happening and then a flashback on their
story and convoluted plot hopefully it
all makes sense in the end like everyone
does a good job in this movie some
people are more important and more
relevant than others some people you
think are gonna be the main focus of it
all of it they're not was it a little
more convoluted than it needed to be
yeah I get the novelty of flashing back
and then coming back and then flashing
back for that person and flashing back
to that person but I think this movie
used that novelty of jumping around a
bit too much there's actually this scene
in the last act the last act really has
all the momentum it all just comes to a
head and I really like the last act but
even when the final act is going there
does one more flashback and you kind of
die felt the momentum stopped like he
hit a brick wall like oh all right we're
going back again it quickly goes back to
the present but I feel like it's like a
racer who's almost the finish line and
they stub their toe they don't fall they
just kind of do a stumble and then they
keep running and they get to the finish
line in the first two acts of this movie
I just wish the movie would sit still
long enough for you to get invested
watch the plot going forward before it
hits the reset button and takes you back
and shows you a flashback when a
flashback is a scene in and of itself or
when it bounces over to another
characters perspective and you
essentially see the first act again it
takes the momentum and resets the
momentum so it's like a bungee cord
effect the momentum is going forward and
it snaps you back then you have to react
spear e'en stat momentum again you can
do that a couple times but it starts
feeling repetitive at a point if a movie
doesn't too much you're like this move
you might have done it a bit too much
suppose that's why I like the last act
of this movie best it's the act of this
movie that sits still long enough for
you to just enjoy the scene and
intensity as it's rolling out towards it
it has one moment of flashback sure like
I said but all in all the last act of
this movie is what brings it all
together it does feel like liquid 25
years ago and a lot of directors like
I'm gonna be like Tarantino I'm gonna do
what he did it's like it's been 25 years
since well let's start doing that again
ever if you're gonna try to do a
Tarantino esque movie I know he hasn't
cornered the entire market it's not like
he owns the concept of doing something
like this but what sets Tarantino apart
is he has engaging dialogue throughout
but this movie doesn't have that
engaging dialogue I bring it up here
because this is the writer and director
of cabin in the woods habit in the woods
had that fun dialogue there are large
sections of time I'm like I'm just
watching people do [ __ ] I would just
expect the director of cabin in the
woods to have more fun with this kind of
concept in the dialogue Department it's
unfair to imply that I wasn't intrigued
like I'm intrigued as to why there's a
secret passageway behind the rooms I'm
intrigued as to why that person is tied
up but still a tone and pacing just felt
a little flat for me this flatter than
should be flatter than the implication
of the editor because the movies already
doing the quirky little all bounce of
that person now you see their
perspective bounce to here now you've
seen a flashback at method and formats a
bit fun but the movie never has as much
fun as that would imply like it wants to
be the super serious crime drama just
with fun editing makes it feel a little
conflicted I don't require every movie
to be funny or fun I just also don't
want movies to leave me feeling like the
directors flexing like look how
pretentious and clever I am when it's
like all right well you have flashbacks
you have different perspectives but in
the end it's still just a crime movie
that's not half as clever as I've seen
before a couple of heartfelt bits a
dialogue with Jeff Bridges character
he's the one you kind of latch on to and
empathize with the most no one crushes
it more than Chris Hemsworth's character
who comes in at the last act he
completely dude he's a Saints deal and
no one in the movie for their scenes is
as much of a scene stealer as Chris
Hemsworth is in the last act as in the
end I feel like I was bagging on this
movie a bit more than I plan to I just
didn't enjoy this movie as much as a lot
of other people did I'd rather watch
snatch or any Tarantino movie really it
does feel like second-rate hateful eight
or even lucky number Slevin probably
that before this and this really isn't a
complaint just an observation but the
novelty of having this hotel that's
right on the state line between Nevada
and California literally the state line
goes through the hotel so one size
Nevada one side's California it's just
it's that it's a novelty in thinking
about it there's nothing in the movie
that really makes that relevant at all
you could have a hotel that's in the
middle of California or a hotel that's
in the middle of Nevada and essentially
the movie be exactly the same thing
actually at one point roulette and
gambling comes into it so alright Nevada
still I don't know why they had to have
the hotel divided by the state line
unless a it's a real place which I don't
know
or be it's a cool thing in the trailer
that would get people to watch the movie
and here it is this is gonna make half
of you knuckle up and the other half is
gonna validate you but I always say I
never claimed to be a critic or a role
model and here's why
gun to my head I'd probably rather watch
venom again than this again so I will
say bad times at the El Royale would
probably be a better time if you're
drunk ya know it's a party this kinda
actually makes me put my tinfoil hat on
you hear Hollywood stories about how a
director of that movies actually not the
director of that movie it was actually
the producer like the Wachowski produce
V for Vendetta Joss Whedon produce cabin
in the woods Drew Goddard directed cabin
in the woods and you hear stories about
how the Wachowskis might have directed V
for Vendetta because the director of V
for Vendetta hasn't done anything that's
been like V for Vendetta or felt like
the director of V for Vendetta
in fact V for Vendetta feels more like
the Wachowski directed it and that goes
for cabin in the woods the Hollywood
rumor is Joss Whedon directed cabin in
the woods and after seeing this I look
at cabin and the woods I'm like yeah
cabin in the woods had more fun dialogue
like Joss Whedon would have bad times at
the El Royale doesn't feel like the
director of cabin in the woods directed
bad times at the El Rio but that's the
[ __ ] Hollywood tinfoil hat those
rumors are just out there but after
seeing this movie it does make you think
what if there's a bad times at the El
Royale have you seen it what did you
think about it or what's your favorite
Tarantino Eska movie that's not a
Tarantino movie they're out there you
know whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]